Nevada lawmaker seeking to rework a law
that restricts schools from suspending
or expelling students who commit violent
acts thank you for joining us on this
special early edition of 8 news now I'm
Kirsten Joyce I'm Denise Valdez now
there's currently a hearing going on
right now in Carson City Joshua peguero
has been monitoring it he joins us now
in The Newsroom with the latest Joshua
hello Denise and Kirsten the statute
legislators are looking to repeal is the
restorative justice law it was passed in
2019 and intended to reduce the
disproportionate discipline of Black and
Hispanic students but instead that
statue has led to an overwhelming number
of Educators now wanting it removed the
hearings are for assembly Bill 285 and
assembly Bill 194. the bills propose
removing or suspending a student who
engages and engages in violent
infractions or brings drugs to class
another is allowing schools to consider
reinstating an expelled student after a
minimum of a year away lawmakers Say the
original Bill had good intentions
and he showed me the pictures of the
kids who had been expelled and it wasn't
overly whelmingly black and brown kids
it was all black and brown kids we do
want them to be restored and have an
opportunity for ReStore this practices
um to occur in whatever way is
appropriate based upon the level of that
of those infractions now during the
2021-2022 school year CCSD had around 8
000 violent acts reported to school
police in that same year there were 424
behavioral reports filed due to students
bringing a violent weapon on campus this
is just the first hearing and it will be
a long way to go before the bills passed
reporting live in The Newsroom Joshua
peguero eight news now